Candid Truth.
>> I want to thank everyone for being back
again at Candid Truth. We are needing to
expose the darkness of Freemasonry. That
is the topic for today. I hope you guys
are ready to see it even as disgusting
and dirty as it may be. It is a lot. I
will warn you. So, please be ready.
Please be ready to pray that God will
open your mind to it, but at the same
time protect it from what it is about to
see. I've gotten so many questions.
That's what prompted this several
conversations.
Many people have no clue, no clue about
what Freemasonry is, when and where it
came from, and what it actually worships
and venerates. All right? So, uh, buckle
up with me. Uh, just so you guys know,
we always are operating with God on our
side before the video starts. So, we
will not be taking time to pray right
now on the video. But, let's go ahead
and get into this. This comes from
Lifespring International Ministries.
It's a testimony story of a man who's
been doing counseling people for trauma
and helping them heal. And he's the one
who will be discussing this. He came for
one of their training sessions. It says
it there. You can see it right here. His
name was Kevin Boemer, director of
CourtsNet. But from everything I've ever
heard, what you're about to hear is very
much in line with everything I've ever
heard from testimonies. So, let's just
dive into it. It starts here where it
says, "There comes a point in
Freemasonry where sodomy is very much a
part of what's going on." And not just
any sodomy, but particularly sodomy of
young boys, preubescent boys. There is a
procession called the male bride. And
young boys are invited and brought into
this ceremony. These boys, they don't
know what is going to happen to them.
They are excited to be at the lodge with
their fathers at this point in time. He
writes or this is probably transcript.
It was probably transcribed word for
word of what he said. Often these are
very high ranking members present and
oftent times members of other lodges are
together for this ceremony. Second
paragraph. These young men are literally
dressed in a wedding veil, like a
bride's veil for a wedding and they are
going through this process. They're
being applauded and esteemed. However,
the result is these boys are going to
have to the shock of their life as they
are going to be sodomized during these
ceremonies. Now, why am I talking about
this? He says we need to understand this
about Freemasonry. Once they get into
some of these degrees and because of
ancient Egyptian sex magic which is
engaged in these degrees, this sodomy
sin becomes more than just a physical
thing that takes place down to here.
When you are first born, you are born
with 33 vertebrae in your back. But as
you grow older, your vertebrae are
beginning to fuse together. By the time
you become an adult, you only have 24
independent vertebrae because some of
them have fused together into one bone,
particularly your tailbone. And that's
why they choose to do this to young
boys. Because while these boys are
young, their tailbone is still separate
vertebrae. The reason for that is that
while they're engaging in that practice
of sodomizing, here's where they're
going to get deep. They are literally
pressing down on those vertebrae to put
pressure on the fluid in the spinal
column to shove it up into the brain, up
into the brain stem and to what they
believe will impact their third eye. It
is to open a portal to other dimensions.
Here, why is this an issue? He says, I
have had several situations where people
have LHS's. He refers to this. I believe
it's a demonic presence that he's not
clarifying right here. we must not be
coming in at the right part of the
conversation when they clarified what
those were. That's okay. But he talks
about it as right here, right here.
We're going to read on. However, the
next week there's a full house all over
again. And this happens again and again
and again. And he jumps down. Let's jump
down as well. He says right here, "I'm
finding out where I have had clients
that experience being sodomized
repeatedly at a young age." And that is
exactly what is happening. This portal
has been opened and LHS's are
trafficking through it. They are coming
and going and because their own trauma
has blocked it out of their memory or
they never thought of it as being
connected to something of that kind of a
spiritual nature. They just thought it
was a physical act. I'm going to jump
around a little bit here. He says it
seems that for the spirit the door is
propped open in their brain and it's
like there's a stick literally propping
the door open. He says right here which
is interesting. I've never heard college
professors brought into this, but he's
going to mention them. He says, I have
seen where college professors who know
what they are doing by entertaining this
literally prop that door so they can
come and go anytime they want. And then
he makes a call to someone. If you felt
this way, you know someone who's feeling
like it keeps coming and going, then you
probably have someone in your bloodline
that has had that portal opened against
their will through this act. It's been
done to them generationally. It is being
passed down. So he says what you want to
do is close that portal. And once we
close that portal through and in
repentance as we're repenting
particularly for all practices you have
to cast them out of your life to banish
them. But I'm going to jump to a
different part. He explains down on the
screen here we have right here. He says
right now I just want to share this with
you about the tunnel of Typhon. It's a
title of some kind. Typhon is a marine
spirit. He is a spirit of depravity. He
is an ugly serpentine little GD. He is
violent and he probably could be
Leviathan's brother because of the chaos
he brings and that is what this sodomy
is intended to do. Sodomy is far more
than a sexual physical act. It is
intended to bring chaos throughout
someone's life. Typhon is actually where
we get the word typhoon. The issue is
about the trauma that is being created
in the victim. He writes or was saying
as heaven must be a person named heaven
pointed out to a friend recently. Trauma
opens the door for chaos in a person's
life. The powers of darkness feed on
that chaos. In many of these things,
there are rituals of sex magic. It just
seems the more evil it is, the better it
is for them. It becomes a practice of
higher level initiates in Freemasonry.
It ends up leaving a trail of
traumatized children that are very
devastated. We're down here now. It
says, "The act of sodomy is where the
enemy's concern is focused on all the
depravity and the ravaging of children's
minds and identity and abandonment.
Where's my daddy? And why did he allow
this to happen to me?" But the whole
thing is fixed on that spinal column and
that third eye in the brain. And there's
a whole lot more to to it that's outside
of our grid. Just know that the tunnel
of typhon is involved and things travel
through t through tunnels. We want to
shut those tunnels down. Now again, I'm
going to skip this point right here is
rather interesting on the screen. He
says, "According to the second degree of
Mithraism that is also linked in with
Freemasonry, we agree that we in our
generations have operated in this and we
bring the second degree before this
court." So he's talking about the
spiritual court where he's putting
together some of the pieces. This is
part of the secondderee initiation in
Freemasonry because it involves
myiththerism and usually is
generational. And he's going to explain
something here in the second degree. He
says the nymph or male bride degree one
supposedly comes under the protection of
Venus. The false gods worshiped are
Mithra and Venus. And the ritual symbols
are the veil of reality, the light of
truth, the chrysalis, veil, torch,
mirror, bell, and diadem. The symbolism
includes a false marriage and a false
resurrection. Now, I'm going to add this
in right now. I need to do this because
I've tried to make this connection many
times. You can go find it probably in
any other time that I've talked about
nuns, priests, and some of the abuse
that happens there. They're addressing
the male bride. Right now, when you take
into account the abuse that has happened
in convents and abbies and monasteries
to women, nuns usually are used by the
priest to be the bride of Christ. And we
just saw that. We saw that this this is
the male bride we're talking about. So,
they want both. They want to corrupt and
ravage male children, males in general,
females and younger children and women.
And so it's everything. It's every
vulnerable state or sex that you can be
to be used for depravity. So there is
there's the bride of Christ when nuns
are used in this fashion as well. It's
our duty to the priest to be open to
this kind of service. And then this is
the same thing happening to male brides
in Freemasonry. Coincidentally, the
Catholic Church is also based on
Mithraism and the Jesuit order is also.
So, let's continue. We were here. It
says again, "Pagan worship of the
created over the creator is involved
leading one to embrace a false reality,
to submit to spiritual blindness via the
veil of reality, to submit to a false
light of truth and other pagan
symbolism." Now, he goes through some of
the things that you would say to repent
before God in the courts of the
spiritual courtroom, if you will. I'm
going to jump through some of this
because as he goes forward with this, he
actually gives you more clues as to how
this all fits together and why they do
what they do. And so right here on this
repentance part, it says there are oaths
that they have to take usually all
throughout. So you you can imagine how
many oaths to different rituals that
they have to they have to give certain
oaths right before participating or
carrying out certain rituals over and
over again. Basically, every time they
meet. And so you have a lot of
backpedaling if you have made lots of
oaths to every occult god or practice
before doing it. That's a lot of what
he's talking about here. To take all
those oaths and renounce them, to ban
them out of your life, to repent of
them.
part of their oaths that lets you see
what twistedness usually comes from
their thinking on this. It says, "The
office of bride of Mithras or Nus the
bridegroom is a sacred office with all
its oaths, vows, covenants, loyalty,
eternality, and fidelity of this second
degree and is in some fashion holy."
This is what they're told and what they
say. It says, "I also I repent for
aligning myself with all the allegiances
in this degree eternally." Third
paragraph, "I repent for joining myself
andor my ancestors joining our family to
this false bridegroom, making a mockery
of the true bridegroom and the bride of
Christ." It says here, "I repent for
embracing the false verdict, declaring
that the offering of the cup
representing my heart and water
demonstrating my love to Mithra is
holy." So, it's a holy thing they're
doing. I repent for embracing this
defilement of holy communion and the
mockery of the sacrifice of Jesus Christ
on the cross. Usually, when they are
celebrating a quote unquote Christian
holiday, they are making a mockery of
it. That whole day is about blaspheming
God. And many of of their rituals,
several of them are all about it. And a
point on that when the Catholic Church
has several different Jesuses hanging on
the cross and one's the bent cross and
one is another kind they are also
blaspheing this very thing and making a
mockery of the sacrifice of Jesus Christ
on the cross. The cross is actually not
a Christian or holy thing. They love it
because it actually represents their
victory. They feel the Catholic Church
feels this and Freemasonry and Jesuits
feel that this it is a symbol that they
wear. they like to see in their churches
as a perpetual representation of them
overcoming Christ and crucifying
crucifying him continually over and over
again. It gives them joy. And so um we
go down to this. He says, "I repent for
embracing the false verdict declaring
that the bread is infused by the power
of the sun god." So, just in case you're
wondering, other times when I've asked
or talked about the sun god, Sunday,
would you have ever thought that this
would come into it that Mithraism
includes this the sun god? It does
obviously. He continues by saying, I
repent for receiving into my body this
bread or for those in my ancestral lines
who parttook of that of this defiled
bread. I repent for granting it power
over my generations. generations is
going to take on new meaning when we
cover the next things I'm about to show
you. So these are things that he's
asking each each of these people to
repent of. And um again like I said it
gives more and more details from it. And
it's quite emotional more clues more
details as to how some of these um
debaucherous things are carried out for
this in Freemasonry right here. Another
thing to repent for that they declared
in Freemasonry is that fasting in
preparation of ceremony is righteous and
for consecration of this initiation
initiation they mean of the sodomizing
of young boys taking place in a dark
cave while reciting the hail nymph hail
new light mantra. The only thing I know
of that starts with hail is hail Mary
full of grace.
>> You forgot to say hi Hitler.
>> That is no coincidence either. It goes
down to here and it says, "I repent for
fasting to attain favor with the gods."
Little G and plural. I repent for
attempting to find true light in
darkness. Isn't this the truth? Like if
you have generations of this in your
family, if you are have been in part of
this, if you have this, it's a
generational chains holding people.
These are powerful words, aren't they?
They cut at the core of these oaths that
they take. Now, I um am just being
touched by this. I actually don't have
anyone that I'm aware of at all. I
didn't go through any of this. I don't
know anyone in my family that is a part
of this, but it's a very um insightful
and touching thing to realize of what
has been done. So, let's continue. It
says, "Apart from you, Lord God, it is
impossible to know truth because you
Jesus are the way, the truth, and the
life." So he's reestablishing the truth
from the Bible after he re renounces the
things that they have done or that they
declared as truth before God which is
blasphemous and apostate teachings. Then
they're going and they're reestablishing
God's word on the the groundwork it
should be established on. It also says,
"I repent for embracing the false
verdict that declares the marital
covenant entered wearing the veil of
reality carrying the light of truth.
Pledge of celibacy is acceptable and
holy before God." You see the
inconsistency right here. Suddenly, this
is part of their pledge. They're saying
that they entered into a marriage
covenant with the boys that were wearing
the veil of reality that they sodomized,
that they supposedly got the light of
truth from. And now they pledge their
celibacy to be acceptable and holy
before God. So does that tell you a lot?
It does to me. Read 40 years in the
church of Rome by Charles Chiniki and
all of this will line up. He had someone
jump into bed while he was a priest in
the dorm rooms learning how to do this
in the seminary. Another man jumped into
his bed wanting homosexual relations and
fondling him. and he screamed throughout
the dorm and the father well the priest
came running who was in charge of that
wing and he said why do you refuse the
love of your brother in Christ so here
you see love in their definition has
been perverted in general love is sex
love is fondling and he was actually
called out for not accepting
the love of a fellow brother in a
seminary you really start to unpack this
you you see that priests monks all
people who go into the Catholic Church
giving and pledging their life are said
to be pledged to celibacy, aren't they?
Does that not look exactly like what
we're just reading? Identical. And it
says, "I repent for entering a false
marriage by false means to obtain a
false sense of belonging. I repent for
putting these false gods in your place,
Jesus." I like what he says here. "You
are the head and I am part of the body.
I am part of the bride and Jesus, you
have made it impossible for me to be
married to you." He never asked us to be
married to him in that physical sense
ever. Sharing an intimate holy union by
saving us from death and eternal
separation from God. I have surrendered
my heart and life to you Lord. So
correcting the wrong in the error and
thought that he was told or the that
they have flipped on its head. I repent
from making a vow of celibacy and giving
my seed only to Mithra. Okay. I always
assumed that if someone was doing this,
abusing others sexually, that they
probably didn't have restraint when it
came to any sex perhaps or any person.
Um, I don't know that for sure in
Mithraism, but it appears, at least what
I'm taking from this is that they vow
celibacy to none other than giving of
their seed in the rights of Mithra to
these rights of sodomy and sexual abuse
cuz they're allegiance. That's the only
time that they'll actually engage in sex
is how I'm taking this. But they may
just use everybody and anyone perhaps. I
don't know. This vow contradicts your
command to be fruitful and multiply.
Yes, it does. This is a male onmale
thing. Homosexual relations and pouring
out your seed, your sperm for a god, a
sacrifice to a god, nonetheless, on an
altar. Yeah, they do happen. It happens
on altars in these rights rituals. Mm-
Some of this really hits hard. They're
also going to show a few things we're
going to get into, and I need you to
understand the bread is important, too.
It says here, "I repent for embracing
the false verdict, declaring that
offering the cup representing my heart
and water representing my love to Mithra
and the bread is infused by the power of
the son God." Please hold on to that.
Please hold on to that because it will
be important in what we're about to go
to after this. He says, "I repent for
the unholy communion perpetrated by this
unholy covenant of offering my love and
heart when you are the only sacrifice
worth remembering in communion." If
you've never seen another cult
testimonial video, which involves a lot
of pedophilia and sexual abuse from a
victim who's been through it, they they
explain or don't explain to a certain
extent, but uh they will tell you the
Bible is used. The name of Jesus is used
that they are being married to Jesus
Christ. I watched this recently in a
video by the soft white underbelly, I
think is what it's called, from what was
the Children of God cult by a woman
named Onami. Now, I'm not saying that
she and her story is great because
unfortunately from the trauma she's been
through and the pervertedness, she also
is in the occult now today as a uh kind
of top witch or sorcerer. But she she
considers herself having come out, faced
her trauma, made sense of what happened
to her, and now knows the meaning of
life and helps people figure it out and
not return to their childhood trauma
from similar experiences. Unfortunately,
it's all using sex magic also and
divining and sorcery and all that. So, I
I had to look her up, her practice, her
website after I watched the video, but
she was told she was being married to
Jesus all the time and was used in
pedophilia by any member of the cult
that was an adult. It could do that
without real cause. And they were said
to really love these children. And so,
there's a connection here. That's what
I'm trying to trying to connect here is
there uh you will find this in any cult
secret society and a cult system behind
the scenes. You will find there's bread,
there is wine, there's a communion that
is usually done. Uh perhaps other
rituals, blood, but the sex, the sex,
pedophilia, and the bread will all be
there in the name of Jesus and being
married to Jesus. It says also, "I
repent for embracing that Venus is to be
worshiped along with the false god
Mithra with their defiled symbols of
Chrysalis, Mirror, Bell, and Diadem or
this degree which surpass any other
religious symbols. I repent for giving
worship and authority to these deities
representing the planets that you
created here. He's breaking down many
levels. It's not just worshiping other
gods or sex or being married to Jesus
and sodomy. They worship planets. The
Bible talks about this doing each thing
the Bible said not to do. So right
there, there's a confession right there.
He knows. He knows straight from their
oaths. Let's go down to here. I repent
for embracing the transforming into a
bee through a chrysalis is being reborn
into a new and completely different
life. I repent for transforming into a
different being other than the person
you created me to be with a goal of
completely new life. This is an
abominable practice by the to the Lord.
So they do some of this sodomy and all
this stuff to not just get power from
the innocent but to also and open the
third eye by doing that to innocent
people but they also are after karma
reincarnation. Right? That's what he's
talking about. It says, "I repent for
assuming this practice could bring me
new life. I can only have a legitimate
new life if I am reborn in Jesus Christ.
Your word says to not be conformed to
this world, but be transformed by the
renewing of your mind that you may prove
what is that good and acceptable and
perfect will of God." Amen. Um, it does
go generationally. It's passed down even
the position which your grandfather or
father. There is female Freemasonry. By
the way, people also the Order of the
Eastern Dawn is exclusively for females
and from what I understand. And um they
do the same thing. And so, um there's
just a lot here. You just He's going
through it right here to repent of the
bloodlines, how many generations it's
been going on and carrying out and being
kept or adhered to and to break all of
the chains of how long it's been going
that this whole noose that has been over
them, this curse on their family for so
long that holds them hostage.
All right. So, that's pretty much it for
the end of this article. I will tell you
that many pelvic floor specialists find
out that that is exactly the age group.
the type of people they're dealing with
mainly comes from sex abuse victims that
they are rehabilitating. So, they know
this to be true, too. I got that and
know this um mainly from um family
members who have been having natural
tailbone issues and had to go and then
they had to learn from the pelvic floor
specialist that that is the case.
Second, there was a documentary about a
um stunt man who knew this. There's a
I'll have to link it below and put the
name of it in this section, but he did a
whole documentary on once he looked into
what's going on in the movie industry
and how dark it is, he learned the same.
He went and researched and met with
pelvic floor specialists to realize that
that is exactly what they said, too.
It's prevalent. It happens all the time.
Next, we will go to something before we
get into uh our main portion of what is
to be known about Freemasonry. They have
to figure out again this is a testimony
of a man who's been helping people and
showcasing some of what they're
admitting to do and part of their vows
and everything. Um, now I want to show
you other clips before we continue. Now
this is where I started researching and
I wanted to understand something. Where
did Freemasonry begin? What do they say
about their worship? Who's it two? And
so on. Right here it says Masonic
curiosities. Let's read it. First of
all, this comes from January 1897,
okay? The Morning Tribune. He says,
"Museum that is to be an appliance is an
anti-Mason crusade. The Freemasons of
America will be interested to learn that
the Museum of Masonic Curiosities
collected for an expose at the Catholic
Congress at Trente is to be kept
together and travel over the world for
the enlightenment of those inside and
outside of Freemasonry." So there's that
connection, that partnership with
Catholicism and Freemasonry already
established in these days. Apart from a
copious library of books dealing with
masonry, there are documents which are
produced to prove the connection of the
Congress orators that Freemasonry is an
anti-religious sect. Okay. It will
surprise most Freemasons to learn that
the simple symbols used in their initial
rights not only originated in phallic
worship. Does that tie everything
together in a perfect explanation for
what is happening? It not only
originated in phallic worship, they
declare, but commit them to a
recognition of diabololism. The
Neaphites, the anti-Masons say, may be
ignorant of the symbolic significance of
the signs, but the masters know what is
meant. For instance, he says, "These
adepts are said to be well aware that
the triangle represents not the holy
Christian trinity but the Indian trinity
wherein Satan as destroyer holds equal
rank with God as creator." This would be
the occult gnostic idea. And it says,
"The museum contains some data to
support the statements current in French
and Italian newspapers that there exist
some groups of persons with diseased
minds who are devil worshippers." All
right. So, I'm going to stop there, but
there's that connection. Phallic
worship. Wow. Okay. Ironically, here's
the Catholic Answers website and it also
has what we're going to see is this
literary paper that they have written it
out. Look at this. So, they mentioned
the the Egyptian brothers, right? Or
mysteries in the other paper in the
first testimony we heard. Now, we
actually see it here. The constitutions
of Freemasons, it says, which makes
Freemasonry co extensive with geometry
and the arts based on it. insinuates
that God, the great architect, founded
Freemasonry, and that it had for
patrons, Adam, patriarchs, the kings,
and philosophers of old. Even Jesus
Christ is included in a list of grand
masters of the Christian church. Masonry
is credited with the building of Noah's
ark, the Tower of Babel, the pyramids,
Solomon's temple. Subsequent authors
find the origin of masonry in the
Egyptian, Dionic, Elusian, Mithraic, and
Druidic mysteries. This is where it
comes from. Egyptians, Dianisis was a
god. Elucians, those are certain other
kinds of people that were ungodly.
Mthraic and druids. Druids of course
are, don't you know, they're witches.
They're high witches, warlocks of a
specific kind in the occult world. In
sex and schools such as the
Pythagoreans, yes, all about sacred
geometry and numerology. They were all
about it being their way of divining,
fortunetelling, and manifesting. Here's
where Pike says something very
interesting. Here we go. Right here.
Masonic symbols can be and are
interpreted in different senses by
orthodox Anglican ecclesiastics. The
whole symbolism of the old New Testament
connected with the symbolism of the
temple of Solomon was treated as Masonic
symbolism and masonry as the handmade of
religion. So did we not learn that
Solomon went off the rails and worshiped
all other pagan deities also? And yet
that's who they're emulating. That's who
they want to follow after it's a good
thing. No. But they're admitting it.
says here it is a handmade of religion
which in almost every part of every
degree refers distinctly and plainly to
a crucified savior. Okay, so there we
the element of crucifying Jesus over and
over again. Following down here, many
Masonic authors in the Latin countries
and some of the principal Angloamerican
authors such as Pike and Mackey which
are the top writers for Freemasonry in
the occult 33 Masons themselves right
this is important please pay attention.
It is in the antique symbols like
antiquity ancient times of symbols and
their occult meaning says Pike that the
true secrets of free Freemasonry
consist. These must reveal its nature
and true purposes. In conformity with
this rule of interpretation, the letter
jin, the symbol of glory, the blazing
star or the Greek gamma square, summing
up all masonry is very commonly
explained as meaning generation. The
initial letter of the tetra grammatation
and the whole name is explained as male
or male female principle, says Pike. Why
do you think that is for the sexual
implications of that? It says right
here. Wow, how did we miss this? This is
the part I meant to read, by the way.
Mackey declares that Masonic symbolism
in its original and proper meaning
refers above all to the solar listen
solar and phallic worship of the ancient
mysteries, especially the Egyptian. So,
they're bonded, if you will. If you want
to go back in time, you would still see,
oh my goodness, the Egyptian mystery
followers do the same thing as
Freemasonry. Interesting. That's their
claim to ancestry. And they just said it
will reveal its true nature. It's
generations which they were talking
about the male genitalia as generations.
The G within their uh square and compass
and in that logo is exactly what
generations means. By the way, they
won't tell you any of that. They'll say
G is supposed to mean they say just God
or the great architect of the universe,
which of course is referring to God, our
Lord, your God, too. Like it's all
benign. It's good or sacred geometry.
But that's what they tell all the
initiates. That's what they call the
public. They tell the public so that
they won't ever figure out it really
means generation and it stands for the
male and female unification within sex
for that unification to happen. right
here in the same sense according to the
ancient interpretation are explained the
two pillars Boaz and Jacken they have
two pillars usually in their uh temples
which are made after to mimic Solomon's
temple and they say the ros the cross
with a rose in the center the point
within the circle the vesica pisses the
well-known sign for the savior the
triple towel think of a Celtic cross if
you will sun and moon hyram and Christ
or Osiris interesting they were the
Egyptian mystery
Brotherhoods, Freemasonry. Now they're
bringing Osiris, which is an Egyptian
deity, into the mix. The coffin, the
middle chamber, and even the sanctus
sanctorum as ad yada or most holy parts
of each temple usually contained hideous
objects of phallic worship, says Macki.
This is Mackey writing this. So ancient
Egyptians, if you look here, look at my
screen. Egyptians, Egyptian origin right
here. As Masons, even in their official
lectures and rituals, generally claim an
Egyptian origin for Masonic symbolism
and a close affinity of Masonic usages
and customs with those of the ancient
Egyptians. Those are the points which I
want to make here though they probably
have many more interesting things here.
This would be another one I found. It's
a write up here also. We quote again
from Mackie. A prominent characteristic
of the godmasonry worships in the sense
of the male or creative principle.
Whatever sun worship may symbolize, it
sets forth a prominent characteristic of
the god masonry worships in the sense of
the male or creative principle. Now it
was in this idea that phallic worship
had its origin. Again, according to the
tradition of masonry, Masonic symbolism
has in it this concept is and is indeed
representative of it. We quote again
from Mackie in the manual of the lodge.
Every Freemason has a lodge. So this is
like foundational knowledge for everyone
in that lodge. The point within the
circle is an interesting and important
symbol in Freemasonry. But it has been
so debased in the interpretation of it
in modern lectures that the sooner that
interpretation is forgotten by the
Masonic student, the better it will be.
The symbol is really a beautiful but
somewhat ob obstruuse illusion to the
old sun worship and it introduces us for
the first time to that modification of
it known among the ancients as the
worship of fallus. That is the
significance of the symbol of the point
within the circle. He's hoping to gloss
over this fact that not only is phallic
worship as we can see but there it is
also sun worship. These are regenerative
lifegiving forces that they are
worshiping here. That is what they're
doing. And as we saw, it's connected
with Catholicism, Mithraism, Jesuitism,
all ancient mysteries. That means all
secret cults and sex out there. I'm
going to go back to to tell you about
this and um you'll be able to see where
I'm coming from here. The rest of it is
just what I found. I'll have to show
representations and pictures as we go.
But here's the deal. On this topic,
there's another connection which needs
to be made. But most Christians walk
into their churches completely unaware
that they are standing in what may have
already been spiritually claimed not for
Christ but for Lucifer. The
architecture, the rituals, and even the
very foundation stones are dripping with
the fingerprints of the Egyptian mystery
religion that birthed Freemasonry and
through it a network of global control
disguised as brotherhood. I've been told
by some people it's just a gentleman's
club. We just have fun together. No, God
says to walk in the light and I know
they they think they're gaining light
actually from illumination through abuse
and ritual of um defiling others so that
they could they could be like yes of
course I agree with that statement. But
no, we are talking about the biblical
truth here. You cannot have any part
with wickedness, deception, secrecy, or
sorcery, and walk in the light of God,
the true God, Jesus Christ, our Lord,
who is the son of God. S O N, not S U N,
as they like to say. They actually refer
to him sometimes not just as the son S O
N, but S U N. mixing that occult
terminology together for that knowledge
to be a seed planted inside of you to be
open to that kind of ideology and
through it. This Egyptian mystery
religion that birth Freemasonry they say
is a network of global control disguised
as brotherhood. This is not speculation.
This is historical fact backed by
symbols, rituals, and survivor
testimonies. Let's stop pretending that
Freemasonry is some fraternal boys club
that makes math, morals, and community
service cool, right? Like that's what
they're all about. This includes
fraternities, by the way. What do you
think they mean by fraternal boys club?
This begins at colleges. Fraternities
and sororities, my friend, they're
recruiting straight from college in a
setting where it's just you want to join
the cool kids. You want to be a part of
that house. You want to rush. And here's
the thing, it's a smoke screen. It's a
smoke screen that is so large at its
core. Freemasonry is an oult sex cult.
Basically, witchcraft revolving around
sex. Built on the Egyptian myth of
Osiris. Here's You saw it once already.
Osiris is brought into the mix. Now,
we're going to figure out why. Osiris,
the first god to be chopped up and
sexually resurrected. That's how the
tale of him goes. And they memorialize
that. They live it. They want to bring
him back to life. Here's why. In the
Egyptian myth, it says that Osiris is
killed by Set, his brother, chopped into
14 pieces. Isis, his wife, finds 13 of
those pieces, but the fallus is missing.
She crafts a golden fallus instead.
Performs a sexual ritual known as
masturbation and becomes pregnant with
Horus. Now don't ask the interesting
questions of really how that ever would
truly bring life. But in the occult
knowledges, even masturbation used in
rituals can birth you into a new
spiritual life even as someone else or
obtain illumination through it. To
continue, this story is not just myth.
It's a foundation of mystery religions.
Period. That golden fallus became the
obelisk and the resurrection myth became
a code for a ritual sex magic. Obelisks
found in every power center of the world
represents Osiris's male generative
part. It's not symbolic of light or
virtue as I like to say. It's a literal
monument to sex magic and generative
worship. The masonic apron, it covers
the reproductive organs because that's
the part that they idolize. It's not
about modesty. It's about veiling the
sacred engine of a cult creation. The G,
as I talked about, claiming to mean God
or geometry or the great architect of
the universe, it's not all what it
means. It is the male organ stands for
generation in their terms. Sexual power,
the occult counterfeit to God's spirit
of life. Albert Pike, as we saw before,
said the fallus and Situs, I actually
don't know what that is, represented the
generative powers of nature. The
mysteries celebrated the union of the
two morals and dogmas. One of their most
famous books on how to do all this.
They're not hiding it. The entire light
Lucifer's perverted penetrative
inversion of creation worship through
sex power and desecration. Let's be
blunt as we need to be at this moment.
The higher degrees of Freemasonry go far
beyond symbolism. They include actual
sexual rituals as we've seen. Some
involving minors that is actually
integral as we've seen as well.
Survivors of satanic ritual abuse had
that exact same thing to say. Being
raped and entered into many times over
and over again for them to spill their
seed and cause their generative power to
possibly seed the next grandmaster, the
next ascended master. It might bring
about the Christ. People of satanic
cults have also said when they've been
used that way that they are called
sometimes the bride of Satan. that they
are called perhaps given the title
breeders, Satan's breeders because
that's all they do is be taken advantage
of and are supposed to create more
babies, more children to be used in this
way for sacrifice, for ritual or
deriving quote unquote occult power
from, as they say. And here's more truth
about why ironically survivors also of
satanic ritual abuse of any kind, not
just stemming from Freemasonry,
consistently describe abuse inside
Masonic lodges, often in the dead of
night when the lodge is not during
hours. Children are raped, traumatized,
and ritually tortured to open portals or
unlock energy. The sexual abuse isn't
accidental at all. It's part of the
rituals we saw integral to their worship
based on the idea that the innocent life
force is more potent with power and
energy when traumatized. Many times the
victim is even eaten. This is where the
straight connection with bail worship,
moolok or chemos or whatever he's all
the same. That is Satan worship and
sacrificing children to him in the Bible
as they they addressed it. They that's
how they talked about it. These are all
the same thing. They're doing this.
Alistister Cwley, Freemason and
Satanist, boasted about rituals that
involved sex with children. He was the
founder of the Church of Satan, I
believe, and was also known to be the
wickedest man alive. These ideas, he
said, have never been renounced by the
occult elite. They've just been
rebranded as symbolic. Churches,
government buildings, and monuments are
still being built with these
cornerstones. Now, you might be asking
your question, what what kind of
cornerstones are they talking about?
Now, yeah, that's on purpose. This has
to peique your interest to what we're
talking about, where this is going. Not
just the abuse, but why we're talking
about cornerstones and building. Masons
still perform dedication rituals
invoking the great architect, which is
really Lucifer. And these rituals bless
the structure before it ever opens to
the public with spiritual allegiance to
their god. Continue with me. Hold on.
We're going to get there. So, yes, child
abuse, sexual confusion, unrestrained
lust, and phallic obsession are not just
cultural decay. They are the fruit or
the gold if you will, the result which
they are looking to get. So once someone
is traumatized and their portals are
open to chaos to be used for Satan and
give the other party that did it to them
light quote unquote illuminated
knowledge, that is the result they are
meaning to get. They've reached their
goal. It is the fruit of the god
Freemasonry serves. Now we'll come back
to building part cuz it'll start
building on itself. So let's start with
the symbolism that you've seen but
probably never understood. We mentioned
it once. The rituals practiced in
Freemasonry didn't begin with the lodge.
They trace back to the priests of Osiris
in Egypt. Again, ding ding ding. Egypt.
Egyptian mysteries. They claimed that
heritage already straight from the the
mouth of Mackey and Pike, people who
write their Freemason books. in Egypt
who were the first to hold up male and
female symbols together before the
rising sun. A phallic wafer held before
a wombshaped disc. This was and is sex
magic. This was and is sun worship also
and it's still happening today. Just
rebrand it everywhere. This ancient
occult symbol means two things at once.
Sex and solar veneration. The point
within the circle, let's pull that
apart. The point is the male principle,
the fallus, which was Osiris, his
fallus. The circle is the female, the
womb, which was Isis in the story.
Together, it represents sex, magic, and
more broadly, sun worship. It's also the
symbol for the sun god raw in Egypt.
Freemasons put it between two parallel
lines, which represents and echoes the
solstesses. Now, how many times, and if
you're new here, please? Solstice
worship, meaning worshiping the times of
the year with a lunar and solar calendar
are all a cult. Please do not do this.
That is where the Freemasons are all
about. This was what Wiccans witchcraft
is all about. But their counterfeit
Sabbaths with Sabbaths, which they call
Sabat, that are the holidays like
Halloween. These are the times when
these rituals involving sex, abuse and
pedophilia and human sacrifice, children
and everything are the times in which in
the wicked occult world it happens. So
Freemasonry does the same thing. Wow.
They don't just worship the fallus, the
solar deities. Now they have the
solstesses and other gods and Lucifer.
Lucifer is a bringer of the light. Jesus
is Lucifer in their vocabulary. Let's
continue. But it also solstesses is what
they're referring to is its root even
though it has the solstice in the midst
of it and the fallus and sun worship. It
says but its root is still the same sex
and solar worship. Here's some proof.
Albert Mackey, one of Freemason's most
cited authors, as I said, writes from
his own lips, the point within a circle
is a beautiful but somewhat obscure
illusion to the old sun worship. If you
notice, this is what I read already, but
I'm going to re-emphasize it. It is an
obscure illusion to the old sun worship
and introduces us for the first time to
that modification of it known among the
ancients, the good old ancients who are
our forefathers whom we adore as the
worship of the fallus. Now, you see
where this is going in Catholic mass.
The round wafer is exactly the phallic
wafer they were talking about that
Osiris, priest of Osiris used. That
round wafer is what they call the host
in Catholicism and is lifted up towards
the sun, often in front of a sunburst
monstrance, the case which holds it
towards the east because the sun rises
in the east. This isn't symbolic of
Jesus. None of this. It's a holdover
from the Babylonian and Egyptian
priesthoods that lifted up sundisks to
their god at sunrise. In Egypt, round
cakes were offered to raw and aten or
aten. Some call it that. The host in
Latin is hostia meaning sacrifice. They
always mean sacrifice whether it's a
sexual sacrifice, human sacrifice, blood
sacrifice, wafer meaning bread. Bread
sacrifice, it's all about sacrifice,
too. And the monstrance looks like a
blazing solar disc that holds the host,
the wafer in the middle. Alexander
Hislap writes in the two Babylons, "The
round wafer disc of the Eucharist is a
continuation of the ancient Egyptian
solar disc offered to Rah and other
deities." Take a closer look at that
sunburst monstrance, though. It has
other meaning. The inner circle is the
womb. The squiggly rays around it,
whether straight or squiggly, mimic
sperm, twisting towards the center to
fertilize it. This is fertilization and
sex magic and symbolism right there. And
churches today hold this thing up high
and bow before it. It's not bread. To
them, it's an offering to the sun god.
It's a symbol of sex union. The Catholic
priest lifts it up as an act of solar
reverence, mimicking pagan priests.
Satan doesn't create, so he wraps up
fertility cult rituals and repackages
them as holy sacraments. Now, as I said,
this isn't just a Catholic church that's
in on this. It's Freemasonry, Jesuits,
all secret societies, and ironically, as
it trickles down, a lot of other
denominations. Do you have certain
things? We'll we'll cover that. Come
back. Be ready for another show that
covers how to tell if your church is
following the occult, dead giveaways,
symbols in your church that will show
you this. So, the Bible says in
Deuteronomy 12:30 through31, "Do not
inquire about their gods, saying, "How
did these nations serve their gods? I
will do the same. You shall not worship
the Lord your God in that way, it
declares." And the Most High rejects
pagan worship, even if we slap Jesus's
name on it. That's what I need people to
understand. They use the name of Jesus.
These males, younger children are all
used to be said to be marrying Jesus or
the bride of Christ. They use the Bible.
Don't get me wrong. They know their
Bible. They use Jesus's name. They pray
in Jesus's name, but they mean Lucifer.
Open your eyes. And that's exactly what
our churches have done. He says in
Genesis 17:10-11,
when God commanded it of Abraham, "This
is my covenant. Every male among you
shall be circumcised. Now, why do you
think Jesus said that or God? God
declared that it shall be a sign of the
covenant between me and you. Why the
male organ? Because he knew it was
happening with that male organ in these
systems of worship in these groups to
defile his name behind closed doors in
their organizations. He knew it was the
source of reproduction, the place where
life physically begins. God also knew it
was also the symbol of man's generative
power and thus the prime target of
restraint for both idolatry and
perversion in pagan religions.
Circumcision was a cutting away of the
flesh symbolic of putting no confidence
in the flesh. Philippians 3:3 states,
"It restrained the pride of man's
generative," okay, again the G that
represents their generations, their
generative abilities, and redirected
worship towards the creator, not the
creation. Many religions are just
replicas of ancient ones. I hope you're
seeing that that are and were overtly
following after this. Even if they're
not Catholic Freemasons or Jesuits or a
secret society that you can see, they
overtly follow phallic cults. Bail
worship in Canaan often included the
phallic symbols and sex rights,
including temple prostitution and child
sacrifice. The Egyptians, Greeks, and
Romans had gods which worship centered
on genitalia, fertility, and sexual acts
as sacred rituals. The Ashira poles and
high places that God continually tells
people not to take part in. He says the
Israelites were constantly rebuked for
participating in this phallic symbol
worship. 2 Kings 17
and Deuteronomy 12-3.
It is brought to my mind to remember
that today it is all there still not
just in churches the public world
secular world how many of them are
practicing masturbation sex with anybody
orgies as many partners as you can get
different genders all genders anything
animals children can you see that it's
no different in the church a lot of a
lot of this is no different in the
church than it is outside of the world
if this is what is in the church I'm
told that not only Are men dealing with
pornography? Women actually have topped
it or met that use of pornography today
and are usually masturbating heavily
daily. And it's supposed to be
considered self-care, self-love. Men are
supposed to do it to be good lovers and
please themselves when they need to to
deal with their sexual urges. You don't
think that's part of this? It's
definitely part of witchcraft. They all
do that. Circumcision was then in
essence a rebuke of these practices
altogether. It set apart Israel as a
people who would not fall into the same
corrupt sexual systems that defined
pagan nations. Smart, huh? It's strange.
I'll give it that. But God knew. He
knew. You see, God's laws are always
protective and not restrictive.
Circumcision removed the foreskin, as I
said, the very symbol of fleshly
indulgence, lust, and man's pride and
procreation. We saw that. He knew that
the circumcision is of the heart,
meaning it represents spiritual
restraint, purity, and submission to
God's ways. Contrast that with mystery
religions like we're talking about in
secret societies that elevate sex as a
path to divinity. Rape, incest,
beastiality, or sodomy, any of them
supposedly lead to divinity. When you
get to the top using so many different
people, you've walked up that ladder of
initiations, degrees, illuminated ones,
sended masters. You become one.
Supposedly, you are said to be divine.
How many people in your wake do you have
to ruin when you get there? Many. You
got blood on your hands? Lots. So, God
knew that this meant when he wanted
circumcision that it was spiritual
restraint, submission to God's ways.
This, by the way, elevating sex as a
path of divinity. It's used in tantra,
condundalini, occult sex, magic, and
their philosophy is worship the fallus,
release the energy, and become God. That
is what they will tell you when orgasm
is about to happen. that you just
birthed yourself into the divine. God's
philosophy is die to self, cut off the
flesh, and live by my spirit. Now, that
satanic cult survivor I was talking
about, she said that they were
consistently being told in these acts,
you are marrying Jesus through this. I
am Jesus. Do not resist me. You want
Jesus's golden seed within you. Think of
the golden the golden egg, you guys. The
golden egg, Reebis. Please go watch my
androgyny thing. It explains this. This
is the gold the philosopher stone that
they wish they talk about in children.
All these concepts come together. Child
abuse and gold created in someone is by
using the child in in others through
bloodshed and sacrifice. That is the
ancient definition. Please go watch
those ones. Our our shows on cosmic egg
and my show on androgyny. It will bring
those concepts together. So in the
modern world, we're seeing a resurgence
of genital obsession. How many people
are wearing shirts that are completely
obscene? Also songs about it. So, in
obsession with gender, sex changes,
phallic statues, pornography, and the
desecration of innocence, it's been
brought back. And it's the same spirit
as Bale and Osiris, just with digital
temples instead of stone ones. Now, why
do they say that? And just like ancient
times, this is linked to child abuse,
confusion, and unrestain unrestrained
perversion. It's Satan's old playbook
from antiquity. God's solution remains
the same. Cut away the flesh, walk in
the spirit, and worship him alone as
creator. He was a spiritual boundary
maker when he wanted to institute
circumcision. In Masonic lodges, the
point in a circle is often displayed
between two parallel lines. We saw that
it represents, by the way, not just the
solstesses. It also represents the
allseeing eye of the sun, a nod to
ancient solar fertility cults. The holy
wafer holding it up towards the rising
sun is not biblical at all. It is
directly borrowed from sun worship
rituals. Sundisks, as we were talking
about, were worshiped and often shown
above the head of Isis or Horus. You
know this priests would offer round
cakes or discs as a symbol of the sun
god holding them up during sunrise
rights. Think of Easter please. The
eucharistic wafer is round like the sun
called the host and from the Latin
hostia means sacrifice and those who
aren't spiritually awake are deceived
just as revelation 12:9 warns that old
serpent called the devil and Satan which
deceives the whole world. Do not inquire
says the Lord about their gods saying
how did they serve their gods? I will do
the same. Freemasonry is decentralized,
secretive, and protected by networks of
influence that influence judges, law
enforcement, politicians, doctors, and
the media legally is all hidden is what
they're trying to say. And elsewhere,
because of this structure, abuse, here
we go. This is why this matters in the
legal system. Because abuse within
Freemasonry is then harder to trace.
It's rarer to prosecute, meaning it
rarely does get prosecuted ever, which
means person walks away free from having
done it, and is less publicly exposed,
but not because it doesn't exist. You
saw the testimonies I heard and told you
that it happens a lot. Satanic ritual
abuse, which is supposedly just for
Luciferians and Satanists, happens a lot
at Masonic lodges. They go to those
meetings sometimes just to gain
illuminated knowledge. Therapists
working with these victims have heard
hundreds of accounts where perpetrators
are high ranking Freemasons. Ex-masons
such as Bill
Noblein and John Salza, both of whom
left Freemasonry, have openly spoken
about occult rituals, secrecy, oaths,
and the spiritual corruption behind the
lodge. Ironically, Bill Schnobelin also
became a Luciferian, a Satanist, an
Illuminati member, a Freemason, and a
Mormon bishop. All of which please go
watch his thing. They're all connected.
And it says here that from their
testimonies of these people, there are
underground rooms in Masonic lodges.
Black mass style rituals involving
children. Black mass. Where do we get
the word mass in a religion where it's
used? Catholicism. The use of
traumabased mind control is also used.
And multi-generational abuse networks
are formed protected by the Masonic
hierarchies. Fritz Spring Meers. The
Illuminati formula to create an
undetectable mindcontrolled slave
discusses the Masonic influence and
infrastructure behind elite ritual
abuse. Carl Roots, just to give credence
to this, it does exist. It is a thing,
was an MK ultra survivor and he names
Masonic linked figures in her book. A
nation betrayed is what it's called.
Thomas Sheridan, an Irish investigator,
claimed widespread abuse tied to
Freemasonry in the UK and Ireland,
linked to both political protection and
media silence. Freemasonry operates in
levels as we know. Low-level masons are
called blue lodges are often unaware of
the dark practices above and highderee
masons such as a Scottish right 30th and
York right and higher are the ones
implicated in esoteric rituals including
baffamit invocations sex magic and
luciferian teachings. The lodge swears
members to secrecy including binding
yourself under no less a penalty than
that of having to cut your throat across
your own throat. Because of these bold
oaths, victims are threatened.
Generationally, they're young and don't
know what they are even vowing and
members are silenced and law enforcement
is often involved in the lodges. They
are members and our police, judges, and
sheriffs alike. So, while they're hiding
all of the scandals that are going on
for the Catholic Church and want to put
an end to it, the scandals are not
really silenced in Freemasonry. No one's
working hard to silence them. Why?
Because if you're public facing like the
Catholic Church, you have to care about
your public image. And whether that's
true or not, they're going to cover up
any dirty details. Freemasonry never
claimed really legally to be a public-f
facing good organization. So a lot of
things aren't they're secret, but
they're not covered up. They're just
rumors or scandals that are heard of
stories. They're there. The Masonic
network is like a hidden shadow
structure, much like Babylon, appearing
respectable on the surface, but
concealing deep darkness beneath. The
Bible says, "Have no fellowship with the
unfruitful works of darkness, but rather
expose them." Ephesians 5:1.
Freemasonry's esoteric roots, Luciferian
doctrine, and the patterns of secrecy
and protection make it an ideal
structure for abuse. And many survivors
have bravely stepped forward to say
that's exactly what it's been used for.
Now, you might be asking yourself,
"Well, I don't I'm not a part of all the
different types of organizations and uh
my church is not a secret society and
all this stuff." Well, listen up. Start
looking around because the churches have
all been infiltrated. Here's how. Let's
begin with Second Thessalonians 2:3. It
says, "Let no one deceive you by any
means, for that day shall not come
except there come a falling away first."
We are in that time now. Most churches,
denominations, and movements include NR,
the New Apostolic Reformation,
ecumenical movements, megaurches,
and mainline Protestant denominations
have departed from sound doctrine and
are following another Jesus. Here's how.
The New Apostolic Reformation claims to
bring revival, but in reality is
promoting spiritual experiences over
scriptural. Its exalting modernday
apostles and prophets teaches kingdom
now or seven mountain mandate theology
which is rooted in dominionism not human
humility. It mixes kundalini type
manifestations such as uncontrollable
laughter, drunk in the spirit, shaking
and fire tunnels all of which mirror
Hindu and pagan rights not biblical
revival. These movements often include
many of the rights of Freemasonry
unknowingly elements of them. false
worship of the Holy Spirit. Their Sunday
worship with the sun god Sunday. Their
use of circular stages, sunburst,
lighting and symbols of light are very
occult and freemasonic songs that invoke
fire, energy or awakening. Revival
movements often based on energy
manifestations, not biblical conviction.
So, let's be clear, nearly all, and I
will just say all, all denominations
trace their structure or rituals back to
Rome. The Rome and Rome traces its
foundation to Babylon and Egypt. But
that is to say, we need to know where
things come from. But Jesus and his
disciples were the only way. Jesus is
the only way, by the way. He is God and
also the son of God. S O N. But he has
nothing to do with sun worship nor nor
do they have anything to do with
Babylon, Egypt, or Rome. These are the
things God calls us out of constantly.
And they don't include rituals. So no
denomination today is pure. It is not
clean. I don't care if you're in the
Hebrew, if you are Hebrew, if you're
Jewish, you're not. It is not pure. It
is not clean. You have to all you have
to do is look at cabalism and how a lot
of their symbols and stories,
mythologies and rituals all tie back to
the same stuff we're talking about here.
So that is to say, you don't want to be
non-denominational necessarily either.
You just want to follow Christ alone and
his word. That is my point. So let's go
over it a little bit. Catholicism openly
incorporate sun worship, wafer
elevation, idol veneration, Mary, the
saints, and Sunday rest, violating all
ten commandments. Lutheran, Methodists,
Presbyterians, inherited Sunday worship,
pagan holidays, and the infant baptism
from Rome. Evangelicals often promote
emotionalism, seeker-friendly doctrines,
and lawlessness, such as we're not under
the law. In vain do they worship me,
says the Lord, teaching as doctrines the
commandments of men instead. Mark 7:7.
So who actually keeps all ten
commandments today? That'll be another
show. Here's some interesting
connections as well. We have to
understand the system of false worship
at its root where where it started with
Babylon. It started with Nimrod as a
father deified as a son or the son god.
Smearis his mother whom he wed to be his
wife. So incest in the family already
was there. Perversion as the goddess of
fertility and birthing the womb cult.
and Tamuz their son when he died when
Nimrod died she gave birth to Tamuz as a
resurrected son born on December 25th
worshiped as divine this system worship
worships the son Bale and Ra and
venerates the goddess mother system such
as Ishtar Isis and Mary worship it
venerates the miraculous child known as
Tamuz or Horus in the story of Osiris's
fallus and this is a mystery Babylon
system in revelation 17 carried forward
by the Egyptian religions Greek and
Roman paganism and ultimately The Roman
Catholic Church Alexander Hislop states
after the reformation most Protestant
denominations all of a sudden kept
Sunday sun worship to the sun god on
Sunday. Pagan holidays all of a sudden
came up with Christmas venerating tamuz
and Easter Ishtar. Trinitarian structure
was instituted inherited from Catholic
creeds and rejection of the fourth
commandment which totally annihilates
the Sabbath. Even if you call it the
Sabbath on Sunday, it is not kept on the
day that God commanded. It is not the
Sabbath and you must cease all work on
that day. So if you claim that you I
Sabbath every day, you be a lazy
individual, my friend. You cannot work
on the Sabbath according to God's
commands regarding the Sabbath. Nor can
your servants, your maid servants or
animals around you. They must all rest.
This brings us back to Freemason idea.
Actually, I need you to hear something.
There's a hidden thread in all of this.
Contrast all of what I've just said in
our modern churches today, which have
denominations versus other systems of
worship. and fallus phallic worship of
the male organ which represents the sun
as well. You have obelisks, upright
stones, poles and towers that are
symbols of the male regenerative
organative organ. The fallus represents
verility, power, resurrection, and the
sun's penetrating rays seen in obelisks
in Egypt, totem poles in tribal
religions, steeples in churches, and
minouetses in mosques. In womb worship,
which worships the divine infertility,
you have circles, domes, grotto, eggs,
and the crescent moon representing the
womb celebrated as a source of life and
regeneration associated with goddess
worship of Isis, Ashira, Ishtar, Starte,
Diana, Mary, and Smeis. In sun worship
which is S O N child of promise or
rebirth a divine son who dies and
resurrects can be found in many
mythologies known as Tamuz, Horus,
Krishna, Buddha or Jesus always born
from a goddess celebrated with solar
events of winter solstice for all of
them and a sunrise Easter associated.
All right let's now look at Hinduism.
They have what is called the lingum. It
is a phallic stone, a article of and
which they put on their altars. That is
a stone that goes straight up in the air
like a mound, a male fallus and a yoni
which is a circle at the base of it
called a womb base and are openly
worshiped together poured milk over as
though it were poured seed from the man
out onto it. And Shiva is the god of
destruction and regenerative power,
sexual power in Hinduism. Countless
goddesses are all tied to fertility, the
womb and energy forces such as Kali and
Durga. And in Buddhism, it is born out
of Hindu soil. It incorporates the same
feminine energy symbols. It seeks
enlightenment through inner awakening
such as the kundalini or serpent power
rising from the base of the spine. So
they actually tell you what it is in
Buddhism. Kundalini is the serpent
rising from your pelvic area through
trauma and sexual uh interaction to
going to the third eye in your forehead.
And temples are often mirror often
mirror womb with a dome and tower
structures. In Islam, you have the kaba,
a black stone embedded in silver yoni
shaped framework like a womb. Minoretses
which are phallic obelisks around the
mosque and the moon goddess roots from
pre-Islamic Arabian worship which show
them crescent moon as their symbol. In
Judaism, rabbitic or cabalistic you have
the cabala which open teaches divine
balance between male and female energy.
Shikina as the feminine. Talmudic
mysticism venerates the cphorat which is
the chakras again from the abuse and
getting of sexual power from the pelvic
area to including sexual union in the
godhead to accomplish that same third
eye and enlightenment. Many talmudic
traditions replace God's commands with
man-made rituals. And in Roman
Catholicism, you have Mary the Queen of
Heaven, Jesus as Tamuz rebranded as the
baby god born, and sun worship via
Sunday as the Sabbath, solar wafers,
monstrance used such as in pagan
worship, steeples as a phallic towers,
confession to priests, which was the
ritual mediation used by the occult in
pagan worship, which replaces Christ,
and use of relics, saints, candles, and
icons, which is pure idolatry.
Protestant denominations which still
carry Rome's DNA will be able to be seen
in them Sunday worship in place of the
real 7th day Sabbath. Christmas and
Easter will be kept because they're
really venerating Tamuz and Ishtar and
Trinity. The Trinity is defined by pagan
councils. They actually have the trinity
symbols and definition of it in the
background that you don't know of that
is actually referencing pagan deities.
Immortal soul doctrine meaning that from
the Greek mystics who proclaimed that
when you died you went straight to
heaven which is not biblical. Rejection
of the law in favor of grace alone which
which is lentiousness
listed in the Bible as something that
you should never take part in.
Denominations include as we went over
them all the ones I mentioned Lutherans,
Presbyterians, Methodists basically all
all and the ones that are close are
being seated with error. They are being
infiltrated. So there are some that are
very very close to biblical truth but
not these ones. In the N New Apostolic
Reformation, it teaches birthing,
revival, spiritual wombs and fire from
heaven. Promotes manifestations like
holy laughter, drunkenness in the
spirit, fire tunnels and laying on of
hands, speaking in tongues. It elevates
apostles and prophets. We already said
this. It's a false holy spirit
throughout all of it. It emphasizes
unity over truth, which is the goal of
ecumenicism, coexist, and the
antichrist. In the end, they all share
false tongues, speaking in tongues,
babbling, rejection of Sabbath. They
embrace pagan holidays. They worship
music designed to elicit emotion and
translate states. But we need to
understand something. Come a long ways.
We're trying to join the circle of
understanding here. Here's what I need
you to know. Coming full circle as to
what really Freemasons have to do with
churches, their infiltration, and their
construction. Remember how I left that
as a mystery? Here we go. Let's lay it
out. Freemasons are not just
construction workers. They're usually
the ones who own the construction
companies. They're part of secret
societies rooted in esoteric occult
traditions. As we've mentioned, they
will include any and all deities, but
specifically Egyptian mystery religion,
Cabala, Nosticism, alchemy, phallic, and
sun worship. Many church buildings are
planned and constructed by these
construction workers that are masons.
And they hold influence in politics,
education, religion, and finance in the
background. They started doing this in
the 1800s and 1900s. And it I will
describe. They saw churches as an ideal
place to plant symbolic energy and
promote ecumenical unity under false
light. So the buildings were designed to
be oriented towards the rising sun lined
with pillars, domes, steeples, obelisks
and sunburst windows have ele to have
elevated pulpits resembling altars in
the masonic lodges and they started to
have what we know of today as dedicating
a church building using what they call
cornerstone ceremony. They use a
cornerstone laying ritual which is
nearly identical to how they dedicate
masonic temples to Lucifer. of the
elements of this ritual. You have a
public ceremony where masons in regalia
place a cornerstone. The cornerstone is
symbolically squared for the geometry
part. I'm sure numerology anointed with
grain, wine, and oil as a sacrifice to
the gods. And sometimes ashes, coins, or
scrolls are placed inside that
cornerstone. They invoke the great
architect of the universe. Not true.
They invoke the G, the generational sin,
God. And the ceremonies meant to
consecrate the building to quote unquote
God. but is spiritually tied to
Luciferian light only. What does the
Bible say about this? It says, "Behold,
I lay in Zion a chief cornerstone, elect
and precious." First Peter 2:6. This was
speaking of Christ as the cornerstone
when he came in the lineage of man. But
they lay a Masonic stone, literal stone,
as the foundation in the construction,
spiritually replacing Jesus with the
Gnostic lightbearer. Many churches,
especially those influenced by Masonic
donors or architects, are given a
special Masonic presenting presentation
Bible at their dedications. It'll be
given by the local Masonic lodge. It'll
be placed on the pulpit or an altar,
often opened to Psalm 133, which says,
"Behold, how good and pleasant it is for
brethren to dwell together in unity."
This verse is used in Freemasonry to
symbolize brotherhood and unity under
Luciferian light, not biblical holiness.
sometimes has a Masonic square encompass
embossed on it or is presented in a
hidden Masonic Bible case. This Bible
becomes part of the spiritual legal
ground of that church. Symbolically
placing that church under the authority
of the Masonic system, not Christ.
Spiritual implications of this allows
Masons to bless the building. Their
Masonic cornerstone is laid. Their
symbols such as the sun, fallus, and eye
are engraved usually somewhere. And the
Masonic Bible is placed on the pulpit.
The church is spiritually marked as a
temple of dualism, not the most high.
The occult, witchcraft, and Satanism
loves dual duality. It is one of their
core concepts. It becomes a compromised
vessel of a place where false unity is
exalted over truth. Doctrines of men are
preached in the name of Christ
deceptively and a beast system is
quietly promoted under a Christian
label. This is like Wiccans owning all
construction companies and being part of
each high society connections throughout
the world which they are too I will be
honest but they don't usually own the
construction companies but masons do as
part of their name you know brick laying
masons and um they do this and so it's
like Wiccans doing this and then all of
a sudden you didn't know it was a Wiccan
who was building you just contracted
with a general contractor to build
something for you and before they turn
it over to you didn't know that they got
together their entire coven all of other
members of the satanic realm and blessed
the site with symbols etched on it
having done rituals in it and cursed it
for their god to have a spellcast on it
of legal authority in the spiritual
world and the bible talks about this in
1 Corinthians 10:21 it says you cannot
drink the cup of the lord and the cup of
devils cornerstones with masonic
inscriptions will be seen in churches
that have it usually not to say that if
you don't find an outright symbol that
it has not happened but it may have a
compass and a square, dates with an AL
dot meaning ano lucious meaning year of
Lucifer or is aligned eastward towards
the rising sun. Has sunbursts on stained
glass ceilings or pulpits. Steeples and
obelisks obelisks a phallic sun worship
symbol. Churches that boast their
historic Masonic dedication openly
present Bibles donated by Masonic lodges
have tapestries and things that say IHS
on it. use Psalm 133 in dedications or
in church unity talks and are buildings
or denominations that honor Freemasonry
publicly. Unfortunately, it doesn't
matter how sincere the people inside
are. The foundation of the building was
laid in darkness. The spiritual fruit
will be deception, compromise, and
confusion. That doesn't mean that God
isn't at work and his some of his people
who are awake the Holy Spirit, but he
struggles. If it's already been blessed
for the demons and Satan to get into
those churches and own it, he doesn't
have legal ground to really go into it
and inhabit the people within. He
struggles because he has not been asked
to be there. And it doesn't matter how
much you say in the name of Jesus, we
ask you to come in and do this and all
this the music that is not godly either.
Demanding that God be somewhere with all
of these satanic the satanic filth that
we're talking about, that's duality as
well. You are contradicting yourself. So
with this foundation being laid, it is
deception, compromise, and confusion
that ensues. That's why so many of these
churches today have so many vices. They
they fail to overcome sin. They tolerate
LGBTQ doctrine. They accept interfaith
unity. They preach prosperity and
emotionalism. They dismiss the
commandments of God. They were never
fully Christ to begin with. That's what
we don't understand. So are these always
kept secret? Yes. They are hidden,
partial, or selectively public, but yet
undercover for only members. Masons are
masters of duality. They do things in
plain sight, yet spiritually veiled. So,
most people don't realize what's really
happening. They could be doing this at
night or when you get the Tyvec, you
know, that covers weatherproofs a
building before even any uh siding or
anything else goes in or on it. They
could be just closing up the building so
that the view in is obscured and no
windows are in yet. The windows have
their stickers on it usually too. They
could do whatever in there. And the
churches or public think it's just
tradition. So it's not wide widely
known. The pastors and members are often
not told at all what the symbols or
rituals mean. And the ceremony may be
presented as an honoring in the name of
honoring history or blessing the
construction. It is done by the builders
before handoff to the owner. And many
contractors, architects, or donors are
Freemasons. They may perform a private
cornerstone ritual before the church
takes possession, but partial ceremonies
or private lodge dedications happen too.
Sometimes this is no not a public event,
but the local lodge performs a
dedication prayer or ritual at the
building site together. In some cities,
it's completely public, but only
advertised within Masonic or civic
circles, not the congregation. The
ritual might include placing a sealed
box or scroll in a cornerstone,
sprinkling corn, wine, and oil, which
are symbols of fertility and abundance
in the occult, reading from a Masonic
Bible or book of architecture, invoking
their god, and everyone is unaware, even
if it's never mentioned afterward. The
lodge members believe the building is
spiritually aligned with Masonic PR
principles, not biblical worship. In the
occult, the cornerstone is symbolic of
claiming that foundation, sealing the
energy or purpose of that building up
and establishing a place for light,
which is Luciferian light, not God. So
when a church or school or government
building is built with a Masonic
cornerstone ceremony, even if no one is
told, the structure is spiritually
claimed and aligned. If foundations be
destroyed, it says in the Bible, what
can the righteous do? Anolucius, by the
way, is actually year of light. They're
declaring that that building has now
been declared having the light of Luc L
Lucius or Lucifer. So this is what this
all has to do with with the world coming
full circle. It is a lot. But you can
see how sun worship, phallic worship is
abundant, completely patterned after the
ancient secret societies and sex cults
of their day and now has been kept by
Satan under cover all along. It's alive
and well and it is making its way. It's
not new. Time is running out. This is
why I'm talking about it. The time is
running out and God is coming. But
first, we will be deceived by the
Antichrist. And so, they're setting up
the Antichrist system to look like
Jesus, to look like unity, and
everything is fun and and united and we
do it what you want, believe what you
want, to bring in sorcery and witchcraft
and practices that are truly rituals of
the occult from every vein of the occult
world into the church. And suddenly, you
have no churches actually that worship
God. Not no, they don't worship God in
practice. And so we are um we need to
get our stuff straight. We need to have
our eyes opened. This should help a lot.
This should clarify a lot of what the
world has going on around it and around
you. I have not covered all the
different kinds of secret societies that
exist. I don't know if I ever will.
There are so many. But they're all
different sects, whether they're
Egyptian mysteries or Calaldian or
Babylonian or follow after just the
Temple of Solomon or Wiccan, which means
they just follow the solstesses and
practice their grim grimoire spell books
and stuff. They all are a secret society
from ancient times that are still there.
God says, "No one who practiced sorcery,
divination, fortunetelling, necromancy,
speaking to the dead, adultery,
beastiality, sodomy, deceit, lies will
go to heaven. No one who is a wizard, a
witch, any of that." So it is a it is a
uh cry, a call to come out of the world
and worship God alone. either build on
these things in future in future shows.
So, please tune in and I hope that this
was very helpful for your spiritual life
as it was mine. God is awakening and and
raising up his people to know truth from
error. Please be one of them. Goodbye.
Candid truth.